[Music]
captain wuntch good to see you
but if you're here who's guarding Hades
spot checks are done needless to say I'm
thoroughly underwhelmed huh
from your expression I would guessed
constipated or chilly
there's your CompStat report this is I
move now walking is too close to dancing
and there's no more advance on me plus
I'm hoping my leg muscles will atrophy
so I won't be tempted to use them I bet
you feel real good about calling her
dancing a hobby huh sarcasm the cowards
lie the angel has a place upstate local
sheriff says there's a car in the
driveway right now it must be there okay
they're gonna have to raid the place
without us it'll take us two hours to
get up there or we could Jam not taking
a helicopter you know I was gonna say
chopper look for altar I know you're
having fun but a helicopter is exactly
the kind of wasteful expenditure that
wuntch will use to bury me if something
goes wrong okay sir or is the kind of
thing she'll crucify me for not getting
you could've had a chopper Raymond why
don't you take advantage just a minute
my cauldrons boiling over so you both
have the mumps sorry to say it's very
contagious
you may not want to be here detective oh
it's cool I keep up to date on all my
vaccinations I'm immune to stuff you've
never even heard of but not immune to
braggadocio how's it going with your
sister sir but last night she told me in
great detail about a fight she got into
with her trainer whom she accused of
stealing a hairbrush now she's on the
phone screaming at our mother we'll keep
her out of your hair I'm good at
distracting people it's what I do with
my toddler's all day long how does she
feel about balloon animals I'm sure she
has a complicated relationship with them
what if she comes no balloon
you don't believe moms take on this she
thinks I'm the one who should apologize
just cuz it turns out the hairbrush
ended up being in my car yes I'd love to
discuss your hairbrush for even more
time but I have some pressing police
matters to attend to get you always
working what happened to my fun Big
Brother fun I would never find you take
that back I'm sure she didn't mean
anything by it sir did you ask me they
never should have made the movie Abu
Dhabi I would don't bother Wow I'm gonna
use that please do have a nice day are
you ready for this one daddy's daughter
Hannah's getting divorced hate to say I
told you so but I told you so
you know we should fix her up with her
nieces son what's his name - dr. Oh
Vince and he's not a doctor is a
pharmacist although that might appeal to
an kid and who should we fix him up with
her Oh now sell you know I'm still
getting over the tragic loss of my wife
she was such a strong female woman with
nice heavy breasts excuse me ma'am I was
wondering if you could answer some
questions about that car accident you
witnessed this morning pin Lily's at SIA
good maybe that's it
what is she trying to tell us I don't
know probably never meet your heroes coz
they're gonna turn out to be friendly
you need to get over this Marshawn Lynch
situation real quick now we just have to
figure out what language you speaking so
we can find a translator here ma'am take
a look at this map of the world yes keep
one of those on you of course in case I
ever need to prove my point in an
argument Laos
fine oh it was better than fine it was
Laos so where you from uh where did you
grow up where were you born 20 mime in
there sir a child tying his tie I'm
trying to do a simple half windsor so
she knows I'm a baby look at this see
how basic this not in I called the game
real ray or fake ray and joining us is a
very special contestant captain ray Holt
himself
[Applause]
alright here's how the game works
I will say a phrase you tell me if I
made it up or if it's something that
captain Holt actually said in real life
to an actual human being I understand
the logic of this game great phrase
number one the futility of lighting
candles only to blow them out
immediately is just one reason I find
children's birthday parties impractical
all fake I say fake - I don't remember
saying it so it must be fake it was real
Jerry's kids at their birthday party I
remember now okay another one all right
phrase number two any smile that lasts
longer than a second and a half is a con
man's ruse all right sir I'm sorry that
I got in the middle of your family
business but I'm afraid I have to get in
the middle of it again look if I don't
talk about this a lot but I actually
have had a difficult relationship with
one of my parents yes your father you
talk about it obsessively Wow I would
say obsessively I mean share their time
sir I wish she was there for me more but
although right sorry you look in my
experience the best thing to do in these
types of situations is just talk about
it that's not the relationship my mother
and I have we're not open like that
really because you're open with me only
because you asked me of knowing
intrusive personal questions all the
time exactly you need to do that be the
Jake in the conversation you want me to
just say cowabunga mom yes awesome well
it's not gonna happen
alas we are not cowabunga people
dismissed attention squad today is the
most important day in the history of
this precinct for today is Halloween I
thought we were gonna say it together I
never agreed to them all right as you
may know for the past two years captain
holt and I have engaged in an epic
battle of wits the goal to determine who
must call the other an amazing
detective-slash-genius
the first year by sheer dumb luck Jake
eked out a feeble victory and last year
I let the captain win because he's old
and sad sad because the competition was
so dismal is this meeting about
something it's about everything no what
no
you were behind all this you played me
like horse blue Haim plays the flute but
how I've been planning this theft for
three months I know but I've been
planning it for a year last Halloween
after you won the bed I went back to my
office to do everyone's paperwork but I
did no paperwork I started to plot my
revenge
I began by creating a word cloud but how
could you possibly have known I was
gonna try and steal your watch I know
you were trying to take something
important to me during the year I drew
your attention to my watch
you're eight minutes late you're 14
minutes late you're three minutes early
in Chicago you annoyed me into stealing
it exactly now you had a target but you
needed a plan fortunately and walk
through the door handcuffed to Diaz
scumbag pickpocket is Dan McCreary you
take anything off of anyone anything
anyone the look on your face priceless I
put McCreary into my employ
immediately fast forward to this morning
you commenced your plan McCreary stole
my watch and then replaced it with the
replica and while you celebrated
McCreary put my watch back in my pocket
the watch never left my person
sergeant a member of the commissioner
selection committee is coming in today
to tour the precinct and do some
interviews would you mind speaking with
her of course Terry loves answering the
horror questions oh he is I guess you
don't have time to take off those
ridiculous suspend you all right
bad news captain a water main burst
downtown there's been several injuries
that's unfortunate and the victims are
in our blah blah blah but Tom the real
tragedy Terry Olivia Crawford aka your
main commission competition tweeted a
statement addressing the water main
break and she's been retweeted by the
mayor kudos to our brave officers it's
in all caps anyway I don't see how this
is bad news because the Commissioner
raced like all of life is a popularity
contest and olivia is sitting at the hot
senior table whilst you are eating lunch
alone if the mayor wants to make me the
next NYPD Commissioner it'll be because
of my record in my qualifications not my
social media presence this is a serious
job I know but like it or not the
decision is political and social media
is a part of politics now you need a
Twitter account not gonna happen
the whole thing is inane besides 140
characters is far more than anyone needs
to make a point
they actually upped it to 280 oh good
god so Gina and I are worried about you
you're drinking a second can of cells I
need this to settle my nerves
hurricane debbie is approaching my
little sister Debbie she's a real drama
queen the drama queen of the Holt family
what did she laugh out loud one time
she's laughed out loud multiple times
sir you have a pretty low bar for what
you consider drama once I used an
exclamation point in the email you
called me Diana Ross I assure you in
this case I do not exaggerate Raymond
here judge for yourselves you are oh my
god my trip here from the train station
hey I swear to you I heard the cab
driver mumble under his breath you will
go tonight is that not the most insane
thing you have ever heard I'm kidding
you
[ __ ]
you